non
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur public
sénat ravi de vous retrouver pour un
nouveau numéro d'on va plus loin au
programme ce soir notre match des idées
autour de l'intervention d' emmanuel
macron hier soir sur tf1 et lci nous
reviendront sur les moments forts de cet
entretien sur les maux qui ont marqué
les esprits qui ont même fâché premier
de cordée jalousie chômeurs
multirécidiviste du reçu le chef de
l'état est il en train d'opposer les
classes populaires au csp + nous
tenterons de répondre à cette question
avec nos invités
caroline michel de l'ops et thierry
fabre de challenge notre grand débat ce
soir autour de cette question la
télémédecine est elle la solution aux
déserts médicaux
cela fait des années qu'on en parle des
années qu'elle est même expérimenté dans
certains lieux du pays et pourtant cela
ne prend pas ça reste relativement
marginal pourquoi qui bloque quelles
sont les limites nous en débattrons sur
ce plateau
ne manquez pas d'ailleurs de réagir sur
twitter avec le hashtag au vpn vous
connaissez le principe l'entretien du
jour nous recevons le grand généticien
axel kahn il viendra nous parler de son
livre jean un homme hors du temps jean
c'était son père il s'est suicidé il y à
47 ans en lui laissant une lettre à lui
très spécifiquement cet ouvrage est sa
réponse à ce père nous en parlerons avec
lui mais d'abord la question de la
télémédecine en réponse au problème des
déserts médicaux consulter un médecin
via une webcam entrer son grain de
beauté un dermato depuis son smartphone
ou encore se faire prescrire un
traitement après une vision
consultations tout cela est déjà
possible
on verra avec nos invités quelles sont
les limites et pourquoi ce n'est pas
encore très répandu est mais d'abord
reportage dans la cabine de télésanté de
la lmde la mutuelle des étudiants
installé à paris depuis 2016 c'est un
reportage de stéphane amalia hamza est
étudiant à paris rattaché à la mutuelle
lmde
il se livre aujourd'hui un bilan de
santé particulier dans une cabine de
l'autre côté de l'écran un médecin le
guide pour cette consultation
une auscultation à distance pendant
laquelle le patient est mise à
contribution
tension poids taille le médecin reçoit
les données en temps réel
aujourd'hui je peux vous dire que vous
faites un mètre 73 dakar et vous peser à
billets cependant quelques îlots qui
fait un peu mal corporelle avant tout à
fait normal de nabeul une évolution qui
semble satisfaire hamza en savons qu'il
ya des avancées dans terme de 2
de recherche médicale pour l'heure ces
cabines sont installés dans des
entreprises ou des mutuelles qui
prennent en charge les coûts de ces
consultations
le gouvernement souhaite développer
l'accès à la télémédecine au grand
public et prévoit de créer un cadre
juridique pour que ces consultations
soient remboursés les choses vont
s'ouvrir et on imagine que moyennant
tapas parcours de soins les actes sont
repoussés parce qu'il s'agit pas de dire
j'ai pu sur un bouton vont adopter et
c'est remboursé
ils sont tous savent quand même fait
dans un cadre bien strict pour pas ça
devienne accessible à tout et n'importe
qui d'entre eux n'importe quoi la
télémédecine fait partie des solutions
proposées par le gouvernement pour
lutter contre les déserts médicaux
selon un récent sondage une majorité de
français y sont favorables et les
commentaires vont déjà bon train sur ce
plateau pour parler avec nos invités
isabelle burkhard bonsoir vous êtes
directrice générale de l'hôpital les
magnolias qui se trouve à
boulainvilliers dans l'essonne c'est
bien sa part le reste au nez et à la
pointe de la télémédecine depuis
quelques années déjà on va en parler
avec vous gerald kerzec bonsoir vous
êtes médecin urgentiste et chroniqueur
sur europe 1 bonsoir merci d'avoir
échoué notre avis c'est un commentaire
ces jeux je rigolais télémédecine mais
justement vous allez vous allez avoir
l'occasion de développer tout cela jean
marie vanlerenberghe bonsoir vous êtes
sénateur du pas-de-calais membres du
groupe union centriste et rapporteur
général de la commission des affaires
sociales merci à vous également enfin
françois teboul bonsoir vous êtes
directeur médical chez visiomed group
une société spécialisée dans
l'électronique médicale c'est bien cela
isabelle burkhard je voudrais commencer
par vous la télémédecine c'est donc ce
que pratique l'un de vos services depuis
déjà pas mal de temps
est-ce que ça correspond à peu près à ce
qu'on vient de voir dans le reportage
comment ça marche exactement la
télémédecine chez vous alors
concrètement donc effectivement
l'hôpital les magnolias qui est un
établissement spécialisé en gériatrie
expérimente la télémédecine depuis 2012
et nous expérimentons plus
particulièrement trois modes de
fonctionnement puisque derrière le terme
mais télémédecine il y a une grande
diversité dans les pratiques
donc nous réalisons avec six ehpad qui
avait été choisi par la rs en 2012 les
téléconsultations donc les
téléconsultations c'est la consultation
classique le médecin d'un côté de la
cabine le brio de voir exactement caméra
l'a donc à distance comme une
consultation dans un cabinet la
différence et qu'elle se réalise à
distance le deuxième volet donc et la
téléexpertise donc là nous avons en fait
d'aider des échanges entre
professionnels et professionnels
professeurs d'arts de l'hôpital a bouclé
avec un patient avec un patient
professionnels de l'ehpad de l'autre
côté le médecin coordonnateur le médecin
traitant l'infirmière et l'aide soignant
1 et troisième volets enfin la télé
régulation donc là c'est la possibilité
pour les professionnels de l'ehpad et en
particulier les infirmiers les
aides-soignants de pouvoir joindre 24
heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7
un médecin est de pouvoir valider une
orientation donc avec le médecin qui est
située de l'autre côté de la cabine
jal car dès que vous y voyez quand même
des bons côtés dans cette télé médecine
wyss pour ça je nuance et mon propos en
disant c'est télémédecine parce que une
cabine ça ça vaut cher cette cabine 1 ça
vaut dans les trente mille euros pour
s'entendre dire que vous faites un mètre
73 et vous peser 60 kg une balance à 20
euros la télémédecine la
téléconsultation la téléexpertise ça
c'est fondamental la télémédecine c'est
pas forcément avec une cabine comme ça
ça peut être par exemple des
professionnels de santé infirmières
aides soignants formés pharmaciens
pourquoi pas dans des déserts médicaux
on en parlera tout à l'heure qui sont là
et qu'ils aient un outil technologique
pour appuyer l'humain la téléexpertise
madame l'a très bien dit il ya un
professionnel de santé
il peut y avoir le patient à côté
d'ailleurs est un expert à distances
lassé de la télémédecine qui est une
télé médecine pertinente parce que ça
apporte quelque chose en plus ce n'est
pas une solution palliative
mais là pardon en plein coeur de paris
6ème arrondissement alors qu'il a
probablement 15 médecins dans la rue
mais de 30000 balme était une des rendez
vous c'est pas parce que
je vois là ces gens mais là c'est un
gadget oui il faut éviter que ça ne soit
gâchettes comme vous l'avez expliqué ça
a un sens là où il manque de médecins là
où on le sait dans les ehpad
c'est au moment le week end vous avez
une personne âgée qui tombe malade elle
va aller au palais aux urgences aux
urgences est encombré elles attendent
elle devient elle rentre deux fois plus
malades c'est ça la réalité aujourd'hui
donc je dis ça a un sens ce que vous
faites à un sens je crois à la
télémédecine pour cela comme vous le
dites d'ailleurs espérait s'attacher sur
le principe technique je pense que ce
qui est important c'est de comprendre
quel est l'usagé qu'on essaye de rendre
compte qu'elle est le problème qu'on
essaye de régler et après on peut mettre
en place de la technique derrière on
fait des programmes par exemple en
afrique où finalement le plus efficace
et d'envoyer un sms ça sert à rien de
mettre en place une cabine comme ça par
exemple on encadre
qu'est ce que voulait dire sms de qui du
patient on envoie un sms des prochaines
de santé par exemple au moment du
ramadan pour donner de l'information aux
diabétiques
sur quels types d'attitudes adopté ça
aussi c'est de la télé mais de ça c'est
ça c'est de la télémédecine
après on fait du pilotage de patients
qui sont insuffisants cardiaques ou là
on va chercher à faire par exemple de la
détection précoce et là on est dans un
usage qui est vraiment intéressant c'est
qu'on commence à être capable de prédire
ce qui va se passer chez le patient
avant que le patient ressentent les
symptômes je pense que l'urgentiste
gerald on voit souvent que la chaîne de
soins elle commence quand le patient
reconnaît un symptôme et décide
d'appeler son médecin
est ce qu'il ya d'intéressant dans la
télémédecine en partie c'est qu'on est
capable de détecter par exemple puis il
ya une modification dans l'évolution du
poids d'un insuffisance cardiaque dont
l'évolution de la glycémie d'un patient
qui dealent à jour une forte plus value
à prendre contact avec ce patient et
mettre en place une consultation au
classement comprendre ce que vous dites
c'est que finalement la télémédecine
n'est pas seulement utile pour les
petits mots on pourrait se dire après
tout pour un petit rhume on peut aller
demander une ordonnance pour tout ça moi
je pensais que c'était essentiellement
pour les petits mots mais d'après ce que
vous dites pas ça pour moi c'est
l'opposé mais depuis les années 70 sont
fait de la médecine en france on est
même pionnier en télémédecine pourquoi
parce qu'on a monté les samu mort le
salut c'est de la télémédecine puisque
vous appelez à distance un médecin au
téléphone
ils vous répondent en vous pouvez
ajouter une pierre supplémentaire à
l'édifice si vous faites de la
visioconférence si vous rajoutez de la
technologie prendre la tension
artérielle le pouls etc
vous allez rajouter vous allez
implémenter la précision du diagnostic à
distance mais la télémédecine n'y a rien
de nouveau
ce qu'il faut éviter c'est effectivement
tombé dans une espèce de gadgets ans
dans la télémédecine va remplacer et on
voit bien et encore une fois je suis pas
du tout réfractaire aux progrès assez
télémédecine là mais la télémédecine en
disant on va remplacer un médecin
remplacer une infirmière en projetant
une télécabine lincou ça ne fera pas
forcément faire des économies et surtout
ça va pas répondre à un usage qui est un
usage qui a pas été encore bien défini
et c'est là où il faut effectivement
partir du cahier des charges de quoi ont
besoin les gens et en ehpad le besoin il
est différent dans un village où il ya
trois habitants par exemple parce qu'on
n'est pas d'il ya déjà une structure
médicale ou paramédicale dans un village
il faut aller compléter ce qui existe
c'est à dire pas grand chose peut-être
une pharmacie parce qu'on a la chance
d'avoir un maillage territorial mais en
tout cas il ya plus de médicaux et
paramédicaux donc c'est ses usages là et
à ses sujets indifférents des réponses
différentes est-ce qu'on a du mal à
comprendre
isabelle burgun c'est effectivement on
sait étonnant une consultation sans la
palpation sans les gascons d'appel
l'examen clinique comment vous faites
comment les médecins font pour déceler
des choses et bien examiné en patients
sans même le toucher
non on a tous effectivement je pense en
images la consultation traditionnelle du
riz cabinet du médecin avec le temps
d'interrogation bien attend d'eux on a
attendu deux heures mais on sait aussi
que dans un grand nombre de cas en fait
le ce qui motive la consultation n'est
pas l'examen clinique ni l'auscultation
mais un besoin d'information et donc
combien de le dire les personnes à côté
de moi en fait il faut comprendre que la
téléconsultation ne remplace pas
l'examen traditionnel mais va pouvoir en
revanche remplacé tous ces motifs de
consultation ou en fait il s'agit
d'avoir l'information et où la valeur
ajoutée de la consultation sera la
qualité de l'échangé
au vu des informations recueillies entre
le médecin et le patient là en ehpad
nous avons affaire à une problématique
d'accès aux soins avec une vraie
difficulté entre une population de plus
en plus âgés de plus en plus fragile en
est
pas d' un taux d'encadrement médical ou
paramédical qui est quand même peu
importants et des délais d'attentes donc
aux consultations pour avoir un
consultation de consultations de
spécialistes voire même d'avoir le suivi
par le médecin traitant qui parfois
abouti à du renoncement aux soins donc
l'outil téléconsultation téléexpertise
va apporter une vraie réponse en
permettant en particulier aussi de
rompre l'isolément des professionnels
donc c'est à la fois un outil au service
de la pertinence de l'orientation du
patient vers la bonne structure est un
outil qui va permettre de sécuriser
renforcer les pratiques professionnelles
en ehpad
je parle de l'ehpad mais je pense que ce
que je dis est valable sur d'autres
spécialités mentone ces cabines sont
devenues le symbole de la télémédecine à
celle inverse de la télémédecine est
probablement mais c'est devenu un peu
parce que ça c'est marketing on le voit
bien vous rentrez dans le truc ça me
fait un peu science fiction etc
mais la télémédecine c'est pas ça et je
pense même que ça dessert la télégestion
c'est aussi pour les jeunes c'est
peut-être aussi pour les faire venir
jouer lesquels il n'irait pas je
préférais qu'est une infirmière voiliers
qui souvent à la mutuelle et qui permet
de discuter de parler du problème de
santé parce que le problème de santé de
ces jeunes c'est quoi c'est les
addictions éventuellement c'est leur
sexualité
donc c'est des choses qui sont dans la
rade de l'ordre humain et pas que le
rapport technique
on va continuer à en parler je vais
revenir vers vous monsieur van bergen
justement parce que la question est de
savoir si les français sont prêts à
utiliser cette télé médecine selon une
enquête harris interactive plus de la
moitié des sondés se déclarent
favorables cela dépasse même les 60 %
chez les cadres et les professions
libérales en revanche se pose la
question du lien médecin patient c'est
ce qu'on n'a demandé à jean daniel lévy
regardez il ya une interrogation au fait
concernant une humanisation que de la
place de la santé les dérogations pas
sur le fait pour une forme de
dématérialisation qu'il ne permettrait
pas d'avoir un lien qui serait un lien
intime et d'ailleurs dans ce contexte là
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui alors même
qu'il pourrait y avoir
c'est une forme d'anonymat et donc de
plus grandes libertés la prise de parole
tout ce qui relève de l'intimé
aujourd'hui n'apparaît pas comme étant
un point sur lesquels les français
considèrent que la e-santé ou la
télémédecine permettront justement
d'ouvrir des espaces ils sont
aujourd'hui assez interrogatif
concernant cet aspect là le dit santé
jean marie vanlerenberghe il est bien là
le problème c'est la question du lien
médecin patient exactement et du lien
entre le médecin généraliste est le
spécialiste ou l'hôpital et c'est là où
il ya une faiblesse et notamment dans
les déserts médicaux et donc la
télémédecine peut être une réponse
j'ai vu récemment dans un salon sur un
portable un tout simple une échographie
qui était réalisée par un médecin
généraliste mais qui n'était pas en
mesure d'interpréter finement cette
échographie
il envoyait un spécialiste à l'hôpital
ou dans un cabinet 1ère isr les fans
depuis son téléphone et il avait
effectivement l'interprétation immédiate
ce qui fait que vous avez la
consultation directe pour le patient
d'un spécialiste
une interprétation est effectivement
ensuite la téléexpertise restait là
telle expertise et je crois que ça c'est
un gros intérêt notamment pour les
secteurs sous dotées en spécialiste ou
en hôpitaux on peut sans se déplacer
donc c'est une économie aussi pour la
sécurité sociale n'est pas là juste par
rapport à la question sur les français
sont ils prêts ouais je pense qu'il ya
quelque chose qu'on a vécu qui est un
peu contre intuitif c'est qu'on pensait
au départ que la télémédecine salle et
servir pour le tout venant comme vous
disiez c'est à dire le gérant problème
mais je fais de la télé médecine et en
fait ce dont on se rend compte avec
usage c'est que c'est plutôt pour la
médecine programmée c'est à dire par
exemple vous êtes diabétique vous devez
de vue tous les mois par votre médecin
ou tous les deux mois
quand tout va bien plutôt que de vous
déplacer parfois 150 km devant un
spécialiste
quand tout va bien on peut le faire un
télémètre sin par contre quand on a
vraiment besoin sert convoi qui a une
aggravation là on peut ça peut valoir le
coup de faire déplacer le patient est
finalement une des vertus ça va être
qu'on va pouvoir
juste et l'offre en fonction de la
demande et qu'avant on n'avait pas
beaucoup d'idées de skate en quoi était
comment on pouvait caractériser la
demande et par rapport au samu
traditionnel la différence avec la
e-santé c'est le sujet plein
d'informations sur mon patient et moi
quand je suis médecin ce dont j'ai
besoin pour prendre une décision
j'ai plus besoin d'informations parfois
que d'aller palper l'abdomen de mes
passions alors je connais le patient
quand je connais le patient quand j'ai
suffisamment d'informations sur le
patient et puis je voudrais aussi s'en
vouloir mettre un pavé dans la mare
démystifier un peu la situation actuelle
de dans certaines circonstances du lien
médecin malade quand on parle à certains
malades ils nous décrivent des
situations où le médecin n'a pas le
temps qui se déshabille pour l'examiner
à la poire garner fait fait du
renouvellement des ordonnances en
examiné le patient externe et je dis pas
que c'est de la faute des médecins je
dis juste que ils sont débordés où on
est dans cette situation et que parfois
c'est vrai que ça vaut pas le coup que
le patient se déshabille pour l'examiner
parce que parfois on est vu dans un acte
de renouvellement et qu'il faudrait
mieux réajuster et parme c'est ce qu'on
fait au chu nantes avec les transplantés
rénaux c'est à dire qu'ils doivent être
vus neuf fois par un médecin dans
l'année ce qu'ils vont bien ils sont
vues plutôt télémédecine ceux qui vont
moins bien sont plutôt à l'hôpital et du
coup les médecins l'hôpital ils peuvent
dédier plus de temps à ceux qui vont pas
bien et passer moins de temps sur ce
qu'ils vont bien et on voit bien qu'il
ya une logique quand on est dépassé par
la demande
il ya une logique à voir ce type
d'attitude oui c'est pour ça que ça peut
être une solution uniquement palliative
et si elle est uniquement à mener comme
une solution palliative ça ne résoudra
aucun problème en revanche si on
réfléchit sur l' usage sur
l'organisation des soins sur l'accès aux
soins sur le mode de rémunération
probablement des professionnels des
professionnels de santé
l'organisation qui se tuent soigner les
payer pour les pousser à aller là le
problème c'est pas de valoriser de payer
lac de téléconsultation pas parce que
c'est pas parce que vous allez rajouter
la nomenclature un ou deux axes un ou
deux actes que ça changera le problème
quand je parle de wons 2 modes de
rémunération c'est de permettre aux
professionnels de santé par exemple de
travailler plus en réseau en
collaboration infirmières aides
soignants médecins libéraux s'est par
exemple prendre plus de temps parce
qu'on voit bien qu un effet volume quand
les confrères et consoeurs
les rallyes sont débordés avec des
consultations payer à les 25 euros
mais effectivement il faut faire du
volume donc on a un temps de
consultation qui diminue mécaniquement
donc c'est tous ces modes d'organisation
et de rémunération qu'il faut revoir
et parmi cette organisation ou une fois
que ça sera revu c'est remettre à plat
les choses et bien à ce moment là il y
aura la télémédecine qui pourra
intervenir ou la télé expertise ou la
téléconsultation ou la téléassistance
parce que quand le confrère parle de
capteurs etc
c'est aussi de la téléassistance mais en
tout cas à penser qu'une cabine ou je ne
sais quoi télémédecine sans revoir la
l'organisation des soins sur le
territoire
je pense que c'est complètement
illusoire et c'est même relativement
dangereux parce que ça va tirer en
termes qualitatifs et de sécurité des
soins vers le bas et pas vers le haut
sauf que globalement moi le message que
j'entends ce soir c'est que finalement
la télémédecine a beaucoup de bienfaits
et je ne vois je ne vois que des
expériences pilotes je ne vois pas que
cela se démocratise pourquoi pour nous
l'expliquer pour un problème de
financement puisqu'elle avec olympique
c'est à dire que jusqu'à présent
effectivement l'expérimentation pourquoi
et pourquoi on est resté au stade
d'expérimentation puisque les
financements étaient faits sur des
crédits par définition non pérenne et
que hormis quelques actes très ciblé les
actes les activités de téléconsultation
de telle expertise n'était pas tarifé en
tant que tel donc ça reposait sur la
bonne volonté des établissements de
vouloir tester ses débuts dans le projet
de loi de finances de la sécurité
sociale donc qui a effectivement le
compense une volonté avec derrière une
ligne de crédit donc pour les
équipements bien sûr mais aussi il ya un
problème c'est la rémunération de l'acte
il ya plusieurs personnes qui entrent en
jeu le médecin généraliste par exemple
spécialistes éventuellement un
intermédiaire donc comment réalise-t-on
ses actes il est la question des
assurances si un médecin c'est un
mauvais diagnostic par visioconférence à
question et là on se retourne contre le
médecin est ce que le médecin est
assurée ce qu'on veut porter la charge
est généralement ses couverts par la
responsabilité civile professionnelle à
condition d'en avoir fait un étudiant
et des assureurs qui fonde la
responsabilité mettre en place si c'est
un acte médical
ça va être considérée comme une
responsabilité civile d'un acte d'un
acte médical mais au delà de la
rémunération à l'acte
est ce qu'il faut pour en profiter
justement pour revoir le mode de
rémunération est ce que l'acte est
encore l'échelle de mesure pertinente en
2017 avec une épidémie de pommes malades
chroniques
il faut suivre régulièrement et c'est le
cas avec des actes et des durées d'actes
qui sont différentes
peut-être que évoluer vers mais là aussi
il ya des choses qui sont prévues sous
le mot d'excusé d'évoluer sur du
parcours de soins des vallées sur des
échantillons d'eau sur des choses très
pragmatique par exemple on parle souvent
du forfait et requérants donc il est
question de mettre en place parce que
l'infirmier qui va déclencher la
téléconsultation d'épancher l'accès aux
médecins
c'est lui qui va en fait faire marcher
la mécanique et comme d'habitude c'est
en général lui qui est le moins bien
payé dans la chaîne et donc ça je pense
que c'est quelque chose qui est hyper
important dans ce conte et andra mettre
en place c'est qu'il faut que les gens
qui sont les requérants et pas seulement
le spécialiste requis soient rémunérés
si on veut que le la réorganisation et
je pense existe développe car là dehors
du fait qu'on est bien plein parce qu'on
vient de terminer le passage à la
tarification à l'acte je pense que tout
ce qu'on a dit jusqu'à présent le montre
qu'effectivement si on allait sur une
approche forfaitaire ça serait
intéressant parce que justement je peux
mieux répartir des efforts et la
politique actuelle va dans ce sens là
vendredi dernier je lui disais le
premier ministre était à chalureau
deviennent pour présenter un plan de
lutte contre les déserts médicaux
écouter edouard philippe qui a
effectivement insisté notamment sur la
télémédecine
nous allons inscrire la télémédecine
dans le droit commun dès 2018 ce qui
permettra après la négociation
nécessaire d'établir un tarif de
consultation à distance et donc de
rémunérer les professionnels de santé
qui pratiquent ce type de consultation
et d'ici 2020 tous les ehpad et plus
largement tous les territoires en
difficulté seront équipés d'un matériel
de téléconsultation ça permettra
d'éviter des hospitalisations inutiles
ça permettra là encore d'améliorer la
qualité de service je crois premier mis
5 6 2 sur effectivement le paiement à
l'acte
on évoquait le parcours de soin et je
crois que c'est aussi inscrit dans le
plfss sous forme je dirais c'est une
ouverture assez fort entre notamment
l'hôpital et la médecine de ville
je crois aussi ne faut pas l'oublier
qu'en 2018 on va avoir la généralisation
du dossier médical partagé et évidemment
je le sais je suis intervenu à tous les
pays ça c'est une vraie question la
confidentialité la protection des
données
le méthane et médicales question aussi
qu'il faudra anticiper c'est qu'on est
dans ce qu'on appelle la transition
démographique sterk on a un pays qui vit
est un pays qui vieillit je voudrais pas
qu'on met la charrue avant les boeufs
comme on le fait que l'ambulatoire en
disant vous rentrez le matin vous êtes
au père et vous ressortez le soir et
donc on supprime les lie donc ça fait
des économies effectivement sauf que le
pays vieillissant les patients ne
peuvent pas rentrer chez eux et donc ya
pas de lit on pousse l'ambulatoire avec
des patients qui ne sont pas dans les
critères d'ambulatoire il faudrait pas
que ce soit la même chose avec la
télémédecine gnac de dire la
télémédecine va remplacer des médecins
ou des infirmières et cetera va
remplacer ce lien humain avec des
patients qui seraient malheureusement
pour des raisons de vieillissement pour
des raisons cognitive on voit pas un
patients déments rentrer dans une cabine
ont utilisé à smara oui je suis d'accord
avec toi mais c'est important je pense
qu'il ya quelque chose elle passe
quelque chose d'important en tout cas
moi j'ai vu dans la pratique et je pense
que isabelle ira dans le même sens c'est
que moi j'ai vu beaucoup de patients qui
sont devenus plus observant éclaté à une
médecine parce qu'en fait la promesse
qu'on leur fait c'est depuis longtemps
resté à la maison
et qu'en fait ça ça les intéresse et si
je leur dis vous allez augmenter votre
espérance de vie de 2 4% à 5 ans ça ils
s'en fichent
par contre s'il arrive à voir qui
restent à la maison ah ça améliore
vraiment leur qualité possible bien sûr
et barnes plus c'est plus important pour
eux que des filles en présentiel avec
leur médecin parce que ça c'est un peu
une vue du médecin qui croient que c'est
vraiment indispensable pour le patient
de le voir en physique alors que le
passage en baisse ce qu'il veut ce qu'il
préfère c'est la série de soins
il est très concrète on parle de
télémédecine pour les déserts médicaux
il n'y a pas de connexion internet ont
pas encore en tout cas
c'est quand même un problème concret oui
oui le préalable est effectivement
d'équipé l'établissement met
complètement forcément on progresse on
progresse avec des solutions on va dire
complètement pérenne qui demandent des
investissements au départ comme les
équipements par l'installation de la
fibre mais on peut aussi aujourd'hui y
arriver avec des solutions plus souples
donc on voilà qu'en quelques années les
choses ont beaucoup progressé mais on a
vu que le gouvernement avait compris
qu'il fallait faire l'étape 1 avant de
faire l'état comme oui enfin est ce que
ce sera fait pour autant c'est pas le
médicament miracle mais c'est un
médicament dans la pharmacopée je crois
qu'il faut vraiment le voir comme ça ça
n'empêchera pas on fera pas l'économie
de réorganisation organisationnel on
fera pas l'économie de revoir le numerus
clausus aussi on fera pas l'économie des
transferts de compétences entre médicaux
et paramédicaux dont va essayer tous ces
sujets qui sont beaucoup plus large que
la télémédecine mais au moins bon aie
aie aie à une étape est donc dans le
projet du gouvernement il ya quatre
priorités dont celle de parler il est
évident que c'est pas une seule mesure
la télémédecine n'est pas la solution
miracle
il ya beaucoup de solutions possibles
font encore et les utiliser à bon
escient sur les bons terrains sur les
territoires qui sont vraiment en
souffrance on ne va pas utiliser les
mêmes arguments les mêmes moyens les
mêmes médicaments comme vous dites que
dans un territoire surdotées je crois
que c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre mais
c'est souvent ce qu'on oublie on peut
abdiquer là mêmes mesures partout de
façon égalitaire en france alors que les
territoires sont inégaux par de fines
reste moins d'une minute trente
non mais je pense que c'est vraiment un
sujet sur lequel il faut pas être
dogmatique ans que sur la
confidentialité des données souvent on
est hyper dogmatique
alors comment en tant que médecin
urgentiste la première chose qui manque
c'est de l'information sur les patients
je pense que les patients qui sont
vraiment malades
il préférait que leurs données elle soit
sur facebook mais que quand ils arrivent
à l'hôpital et pas d'erreur médicale du
fait de manque d'information
plutôt que de protéger qu'ils avaient
36,8 de tordre les mains des assureurs
en revanche
tous nos goûts nos comptes bancaires
dont techniquement il ya des solutions
mission de gérer avec bancaire en techno
pousse le défaut de cette cabine
cg une technologie et j'essaye de
l'appliquer alors que je pense qu'il
faut avoir la démarche inverse qu un
regard des usages et voir quelle est la
bonne technologie pour résoudre le
problème
ne soyons pas dogmatique ce sera la
conclusion de ce débat merci à tous les
quatre d'y avoir participé dans un
instant notre match des idées il va
opposer caroline michel à thierry fabre
nous reviendrons donc sur cette
intervention des manuels macro et hier
soir beaucoup de choses a commenté il
nous demande par exemple un an et demi
deux ans pour tester l'efficacité de sa
réforme du code du travail côté le taux
de chômage est en train progressivement
de baisser il baissera la plénitude des
réformes qui sont en train d'être
conduite par le gouvernement
vous les verrez dans un an et demi deux
ans mais pourquoi là qu'on pourra juger
de la réussite de votre pari économique
dans un an et dont le juge pas l'action
président de la république
simplement un indicateur c'est un
désaccord avec mon prédécesseur qui peut
être avait considéré que pouvait y avoir
une espèce de réglages selon les cours
en même temps vous même vous dit le
chômage de mai c'est la plaie de la soie
exactement je pense que l'ambition doit
être profonde radical sur ce sujet mais
il faut encore enfant encore faut-il
comprendre comment on y arrive on ne
décrète pas la baisse du chômage
donc on doit donner plus de souplesse
aux entreprises pour avancer pour
pouvoir s'adapter par dialogue social
c'est ce que ces ordonnances fond et
surtout c'est la première fois qu'on a
une vraie transformation de notre code
du travail pour les très petites
entreprises et les petites et moyennes
entreprises parce que là elles auront
elles beaucoup plus de souplesse elles
pourront trouver les accords intelligent
est avec nous sur ce plateau pour ce
match des idées caroline michel bonsoir
journaliste au service enquêtes de loeb
c'est thierry favre rédacteur en chef
adjoint challenge merci infiniment à
tous les deux d'avoir accepté notre
invitation et nous demandent donc un an
et demi deux ans pour tester
l'efficacité de sa réforme du travail ça
vous paraît être un délai raisonnable
envoie une demande d'être patient
emmanuel macron on a un peu l'impression
qui nous fait le coup d'hollande là
dessus qu'ils avaient donné aussi
échéance en dix ans il a commencé en
disant je ferai pas la même
communication je ferai pas la présidence
bavarde et il recommence un peu le le
même exercice en disant jugez moi dans
deux ans pourtant il s'en défend et dit
je ne vais pas donné d'éléments chiffrés
il parle pas d'inversion de la cour il
veut surtout pas trop s'avancer bas et
en même temps il donne un chiffre il dit
en des vous dans un an et demi deux ans
donc j'ai quand même une contradiction
là dessus dans sa communication sur le
fond si on pense qu'il a raison
évidemment ce ne sont pas des mesures
qui ont effet tout de suite mais je vois
pas bien ce qui permet de dire dans 18
mois ou dans deux ans et 16 24 ans
intéresse en 18 mois 2 ans je veux dire
pour au test pour savoir si il fallait
que les chiffres du chômage fois
meilleur si ces réformes marche on peut
dire qu'effectivement il peut y avoir
des premiers résultats dans 18 mois
ce sera très difficile de voir ce qui
revient à maquereau et ce qui revient à
la conjoncture
parce que emmanuel macron a beaucoup de
chance par rapport à françois hollande
il est lucide un alignement des planètes
c'est ça il arrive avec deux cent à
trois cent mille créations d'emplois par
an qui est donc en train qui va
continuer un chômage qui va baisser à
9,4 pour cent la fin d'année nous dit il
c'est compliqué toujours accuser les
présidents en compte les chiffres sont
mauvais puis quand ils sont bons dire
c'est la conjoncture non mais c'est à
dire que c'est très très compliqué de
faire la part des choses
et effectivement il faudra faire le
bilan dans deux ans je pense qu'ils
minimisent s'il a donné cette échéance
relativement court il mise tout
simplement sur le maintien d'une bonne
conjoncture
et effectivement les réformes qui sont
lancés ajouter à cette bonne conjoncture
devrait commencer à produire leurs
effets ils misent sur ce qu'il appelle
le choc de confiance est à dire le fait
d'avoir baissé les prélèvements pour les
patrons plus des des carnets de
commandes qui se remplissent bombay les
deux normands iront dans le bon sens
donc je pense que dans deux ans sauf
s'il ya un retournement de conjoncture
il pourra dire ça s'est amélioré mais
après faudra dire est ce que ces macro
est ce que c'est
est ce que ça vient simplement de
l'extérieur et ce qui n'est pas lié et
je vois d'ici déjà les commentaires
journalistiques est ce qu'il est le
premier a insisté à ce point sur la
formation professionnelle comme solution
au chômage
c'est un sujet qui est vraiment le
serpent de mer en france depuis
longtemps on
on a fait de notre combat de la copa
raison de notre modèle avec le modèle
allemand depuis dix ans à peu près
l'essence de ce tout ce qui ne marche
pas en france c'est à dire le déficit
d'apprentissage le trop grand nombre
d'étudiants qui vont à l'université
qu'ici plantes
parce que ça ne débouche pas forcément
sur des métiers donc c'est un sujet
récurrent tout le monde sait que la
france met énormément d'argent dans la
formation avec l'idée récurrente que ça
ne marche pas ou que c'est mal fait donc
je pense que s'il ya vraiment un sujet
qui fait consensus à droite ou à gauche
c'est l'idée qu'il faut améliorer ce
sujet là il nous donne un chiffre 15
milliards d'euros
on ne sait pas bien cependant pour
l'instant ce qu'il va faire il a donné
des exemples concrets hier notamment le
guichetier qu'on peut transférer vers un
autre métier former un autre métier
notamment à métiers du numérique ce sont
des généralités et une transformation eu
ma vie que ça on le sait qui on doit
viser les jeunes les seniors et les
chômeurs de longue durée sera on le sait
on n'est pas encore entré mettait son
rôle et d'ailleurs étaient drôles à cet
endroit là de rentrer dans le
cheminement comment est-ce qu'on va
vraiment débloqué ce sujet qui est une
des lourdeurs française depuis longtemps
alors on avait pendant la campagne
regardez-nous ce projet de façon
détaillée à challenges temps avec ses
conseillers le projet quand on va un peu
dans le détail il est très ambitieux
parce que c'est effectivement un serpent
de mer tout le monde a voulu réformer la
formation
on ne l'a pas fait et il veut faire
exploser le système c'est à dire où
c'est un peu technique mais les fans
sont dit oui mais des fonds de formation
sont collectées par ce qu'on appelle des
opca qui sont liées à des branches se
sont dit mais ce sont des organismes
lourd coûteux qui en plus de finances
que dans leur secteur donc il voudrait
décloisonner tout ça au risque de
heurter certains syndicats patronaux
donc ça le projet est là il y avait un
autre projet ambitieux mais là je suis
un petit peu plus dubitatif
c'était de fusionner les lycées
professionnels avec des centres
d'apprentissage
c'était dans son programme ça a
bizarrement disparu parce que c'est un
projet énorme mais les lycées pro
fonctionne mal en france
vous savez qu'on forme encore des
comptables qui vont à l'assurance
chômage
donc ça dans sa campagne il avait dit on
on y va et puis c'est un une réforme
tellement qui heurterait tellement
l'éducation nationale qui à la disparue
de son programme donc si vous voulez
pour l'instant il ya des c'est encore
difficile de juger il veut aller très
loin
mais tout le monde s'est cassé les dents
jusque jusque là et le chef de l'état
passé pas mal de temps également à
essayer de nous rassurer sur le fait
qu'il respecte bien tous les français
qu'il n'a pas de mépris pour certaines
classes sociales pourtant pourtant il a
continué d'utiliser des termes assez
étonnant pas de slogan maîtrisé a priori
non des termes employés au détour de
quelques phrases sur certains chômeurs
justement qualifié de multirécidiviste
du refus il faut qu'on s'assure qu'ils
recherchent bien de manière active d'un
emploi dont faut vérifier les efforts
qui sont faits et il faut vérifier que
c'est pas un multirécidiviste du refus
donc je veux que des phénomènes de refus
ça aussi c'est ce que nous devrons
définir des blais venise et ready 2 je
pense c'est sain mais je pense que ce
contrôle ça doit être un contrôle de
l'engagement de celui qui est en
recherche d'emploi cette bonne des
licences et un contrôle mais face à l'ô
quelqu'un qui ne refuse pas il se fois
caroline michel ça vous a choqué frappé
heurté ce terme multirécidiviste du
refus ce qui m'a frappé c'est la
sémantique du président qui vient là on
l'a bien vu
l'un des objectifs majeurs lors de cet
exercice était venir dire aux français
je ne suis pas le président des riches
et quand on va dans la sémantique le mot
qu'il a utilisée probablement le plus
souvent c'était le mot réussi la
réussite
il a eu beau nous dire que non c'était
pas forcément la réussite par l'argent
on a bien compris que la réussite était
quelque chose comme arrivé à kehl
entreprises dans la société et il a
parlé de la jalousie à multi envahiront
yaris par rapport à l'argent donc je
trouve qu'il ya dans la sémantique on
sait le soupçon qu'ont les français
aujourd'hui finalement est-ce que son
discours et correspond à ce qu'il pense
vraiment c'est pour ça et on peut que je
vivais un peu exprimé au détour d'une
phrase banale seulement que ce soit un
slogan préparer c'est c'est à dire que
tout le début de long
revue et ça peut énerver et sur ces
questions demande de fin de l'interview
fainéants bordel etc
on s'en fiche un peu à la vérité mais
qu'est ce que les journalistes
interrogent à ce moment là c est ce que
vous ne dites pas au détour des phrases
ce que vous pensez vraiment et est-ce
que vous n'êtes pas vraiment dans une
exaltation de la réussite
professionnelle par la richesse et de sa
renvoie ce qu'il a dit sur les gens de
ce qu'ils sont rien vraiment dans
comment dire dénigrement des oreilles je
pense qu'il ya un déficit d'incarnation
de sa partie sociale il nous a redit
libéré protéger qu'on retrouve à tous
les niveaux dans son gouvernement le
trouve dans son discours mais vous allez
à matignon où vous avez des libéraux
purs et durs libérés ils veulent ils
sont sur la même ligne
les français n'aiment pas l'argent il
faut réconcilier les français avec
l'argent on a quand même l'impression
que dans l'incarnation malgré ce don
qu'il veut nous convaincre
ça lui échappe et réussir c'est quand
même réussir par l'argent revient quand
même au terme multirécidiviste du refus
multirécidiviste c'est quand même pas
neutres comme terme est ce qu il veut
parler de délinquants du chômage sinon
c'est quoi que la balance est vrai que
multirécidiviste est pas très heureux
mais on est souvent étonnés avec
emmanuel macron parce que finalement on
souvent les gens oublient ce qu'il a
déjà dit c'est à dire que sur la
réussite il a déjà dit qu ils rêvaient
qu'il fallait que les français rêvent
des jeunes français rêvent d'être
milliardaire s'était ya derrière ça
avait fait une polémique sur le chômage
on a regardé justement aujourd'hui ce
qu'il avait promis dans sa campagne
c'est exactement ce qu'il a dit hier
soir ça n'a pas varié déjà dans sa
campagne il avait dit il faut contrôler
les chômeurs ce qui est un tabou en
france puisque justement est ce qu'il
dit quelque chose que d'autres n'osent
pas dire et qui reflète une réalité ou
est ce que c'est un fantasme alors il ya
un fait objectif c'est que le contrôle
des chômeurs est quasi inexistant en
france contrairement à d'autres pays le
danemark la suède par un des pays
pourtant sociaux ou là les chômeurs sont
extrêmement contrôlée en entretien
chaque mois doivent produire des preuves
qui font de la recherche d'emploi on
sent quand même relancer ils ont des
entretiens
rugueux il n'y a pas de preuve le c'est
à dire qu'on doit pas produire à son
conseiller la preuve qu'on a cherché de
l'emploi on met donc ça veut dire que
les multirécidivistes du refus il
n'existe pas non mais c'est à dire que
non mais on peut aujourd'hui être refusé
des offres d'emploi rien ne vous impose
de les accepter
nicolas sarkozy a fait une loi en 2008
en disant qu'il fallait accepter au bout
de deux refus fallait accepter une offre
valable cette loi n'a quasiment pas été
appliquée parce qu'elle est trop
complexe trop trop bureaucratique donc
il ya quand même un problème ça c'est
pas de c'est pas inventé par emmanuel
macron le fait qu'on contrôle peu les
chômeurs alors comment faut-il les
contrôler évidemment après il ya la
méthode on peut les contrôler
brutalement comme dans certains pays moi
j'étais justement au danemark où là s'il
ya une espèce de faire mais on l'est on
les pistes on leur met la pression on
les voit tous les mois donc pour il ya
une pression un peu psychologique pour
dire ça marche
oui ça marche ça marche mais
effectivement ça crée des débats dans la
presse danoise moi j'ai vu des gens nous
parce que les gens ne supportent pas les
méthodes de l'agencé pour l'emploi
pas pour autant qu'il faut les copier
mais simplement on passe d'un système où
l'attrait coercitif parce que eux disent
on est coercitif mais on a 80 % de son
salaire quant à 17h chômage
ils sont aussi généreux un système
français où on est moins bien indemnisés
mais où il n'ya pas de coercition et
vous savez qu'à mayotte macro s'inspire
beaucoup des nordiques donc se donnant
donnant ils veulent le mettre en oeuvre
avec un contrôle mais aussi une plus
grande générosité puisqu'il l'a il a en
a parlé un peu hier soir le le fait
d'étendre les l'assurance chômage aux
salariés qui en démissionner et je vous
donne au passage ce tweet de daniel
fasquelle parce qu'il y en a eu des
réactions évidemment on entend quelques
joncs tout à leur candidat à la
présidence et l'air alcoolique illettrés
déscolarisés fainéants jaloux ne sont
rien macron incapable de reconnaître son
discours blessant il ne se remet pas en
question une seconde emmanuel macron
c'est ce que vous avez ressenti vous
aussi car les niches m on n'a pas
l'impression que c'est le roi de
l'autocritique mais c'est pas non plus
qu'on attend d'un président de la
république donc je pense que si on avait
fait il ya quand même un côté où on
n'est jamais content on trouvait
françois hollande passé présidentielle
où il a trouvé emmanuel milingo
présidentielle c'est pas la question la
vraie question c'est ce qu'il veut faire
vraiment ce que disait il ya juste titre
il nous a promis une flexisécurité à la
scandinave
il a promis qu'on
1/2 serait différemment les chômeurs que
ceux qui ont démissionné mais maintenant
on nous dit sous la condition d'un
projet pourrait avoir une indemnité
chômage et que l inverse de cet
élargissement de l'assurance chômage on
aurait un système avec davantage de
contrôles des offres bon ce qu'on attend
c'est la mise en oeuvre encore une fois
de cette partie sociale de ceux donnant
donnant parce que pour l'instant on a
bien vu ce qu'il a été donné aux plus
riches c'était bien la question hier
soir et on attend de voir l'aspect
social et je trouve quand même qu'à
chaque fois qu'on parle du côté gauche
ou droit du donon c'est toujours un peu
repoussé ou atténuée finalement c'est
sous condition échelonné ou échelonné la
taxe d'habitation ce sera super
plusieurs années le long pour a
démissionné mais pas tous les cinq ans
peut-être tous les tous les sept ans
donc il ya toujours le donnant-donnant
il est là mais ça recule toujours un
petit peu l'échéance de voir ce qu'on va
donner de l'autre main et dans le fond
on est quand même en droit de se
demander si de fait il n'oppose pas un
peu malgré lui peut-être les français
aisés aux français issus des milieux
modestes là encore les termes employés
posent question écoutez je crois à la
corde et il ya des femmes et des hommes
qui réussissent dans la société parce
qu'ils ont des talents la réussite a
d'ailleurs pas que monétaire ou
financières ya des gens qui réussissent
dans les arts dans l'association dans
leur vie familiale et je veux qu'on
célèbre toutes ces réussites chacune et
chacun en a d'autres pour qui la vie est
plus dure je veux les aider par leur
travail réussi et d'autres qui sont
fragiles nous les protégerons mais si on
commence à jeter des cailloux sur les
premiers de cordée
c'est toute la corde et qui dégringole
thierry fabre il nous parle de la
jalousie des français là aussi met le
doigt sur une vérité une réalité bien
sûr les français en général n'aiment pas
les riches c'est clair et ça c'est
pourquoi je dis ça passe mais pourquoi
tu sais quand on fait un sondage sur est
ce que vous êtes pour la suppression de
l'sf et personnes la majorité des
français sont contre supprimer l' isf
on doit taxer les riches et quand on
explique on doit expliquer aux français
que nos riches sans trop taxés qu'il
faut alléger prioritairement leur
imposition a eu avant d'autres d'autres
besoins de la société
les gens ont du mal à comprendre
alors est-ce qu'elles attisent les
tensions en tenant ce genre de discours
on peut pas dire qu'ils attisent les
tensions au contraire il essaye de
l'aider gonflé en disant arrêtez de
viser les riches et donc ça revient
cette phrase vous savez sur les jeunes
qui doivent rêver d'être milliardaire
il assume totalement cet aspect là à
dire qu'il était il a beaucoup de
relations dans le domaine high tech de
ces gens qui peuvent très vite être être
riche est alors pour lui ça lui pose
aucun problème que ce serait une
exception qui confirme la règle mais on
doit alors quand même il pousse les
français à célébrer la richesse et ça
dans notre pays c'est extrêmement
compliqué puisque c'est un pays
justement où les riches sont dans le
viseur rappelez-vous françois hollande
qui à l'époque avait considéré qu on
était riche à partir de 4000 euros
donc là d'ssus moi ce que je trouve
intéressant dans macron c'est que il est
sans complexe sur cette politique
il assume les riches il faut baisser les
impôts pour relancer l'économie après la
deuxième question c'est est-ce que ça
marche on a fait une interview de bruno
le maire dans dans challenges qui
rejoint un peu cet argument cette
argumentation disant on va créer un choc
de confiance avec les 5 milliards de
baisses vous allez voir les riches vont
investir
c'est une vraie question parce que pour
l'instant les armes damistes c'est
imparable et de vous dire concrètement
si ça va marcher
c'est à dire que jusqu alors on a vu
l'expérience du cic ou qui n'a pas très
bien marché
parce qu'il n'y avait pas des conditions
de confiance et on a b c d impôt de 20
milliards avec des résultats assez
faible donc le deuxième pari macron est
en train de prendre
mais ils l'assument et notamment
vis-à-vis des riches alors que son
prédécesseur ne l'assumé pas ce qui est
gênant c'est qu'on l'entend très bien
tancé les français trop égalitariste qui
n'aimerait pas les riches on n'entend
pas dire aux riches écouter on fait un
effort la france accepte de faire un
effort de 3,5 milliards 2,5 milliards
soyez solidaires il le dit un peu il dit
encore
j'ai quand même très très léger et moi
j'ai beaucoup entendu les cailloux sur
les premiers de cordée je n'ai pas
entendu dire messieurs très directement
les premiers de cordée soyons juno j'ai
eu l'air il ya quand même un verger midi
on attend beaucoup de ses premiers de
cordée et on attend qu'ils
réinvestissent ouais m'enfin ça nettoie
la ferdi au détour d'une phrase je
n'entends pas dire que les premiers de
cordée en question se sont montrés assez
peu solidaire sur les dix dernières
années qu'ils se sont montrés assez peu
exemplaire à ses preuves c'est peu
moreau ce qu'on peut voir notamment dans
les pays scandinaves où on a une
dimension de l'éthique et de la morale
qui est bien différente de ce qui se
fait en france et qui expliquent que
leur modèle social soit plus cohérent
est mieux acceptée et donc on aurait
aimé l'entendre dire avec autant de
force ce qu'il a dit quand même je vous
le concède au dernier de cordée qu'il
fallait quand même tirer la corde et
garder tout le monde et pas se barrer
exactement je vous le disais ses
opposants politiques ont n'ont pas cessé
de commenter cette intervention
aujourd'hui julie humains nous a préparé
un florilège de réactions
moi j'ai vu hier soir un président bull
un président qui vit avec les siens et
qui ne comprend visiblement pas ce que
sont les français et qui ne les connais
pas il a voulu faire la démonstration
qu'il n'était pas le président des
riches
et c'est tout l'inversé puisque la
réalité c'est que quand il s'agit de
d'apporter des mesures favorables bien
c'est tout de suite maintenant et ça
c'est clair pour les plus riches des
plus riches
et puis quand il s'agit de protéger les
français ou par exemple sur les
questions du travail ou sur les
questions concernant nos quartiers bas
tout ça c'est renvoyé à plus tard je
sais quelle est sa politique
on sait ce qu'il veut faire il a
parfaitement assumé hier il y avait dans
la manière dont il a exprimé les choses
de la conviction souvent du talent mais
moi j'ai avec ce qu'il veut faire un
certain nombre de désaccords la
démission d'assad du vsf la suppression
des emplois
aidés sont des mesures qui que nous
soutenons d'ailleurs comme la réforme du
code du travail
mais pour le reste vient de donner deux
exemples qui sont tout à fait
caractéristique d'une politique sociale
démocrate et d'une politique de gauche
même si cela vous paraît peut-être
aujourd'hui un contre-courant
on va voir que ce sont des mesures qui
sont extrêmement lourdes extrêmement
inquiétante et qui vont marquer le pays
un choc fiscal avec une hausse de 25% de
la csg c'est pas rien et une remise en
cause du système de l'assurance chômage
c'est pas rien dit il nous reste deux
minutes une réaction à cette expression
choc fiscal employés par bernard acoyer
oui c'est le pari des bagnoles bac rond
c'est à dire que essais théorisée par un
économiste très proche de lui qui est
philippe aghion qu'ils considèrent comme
ça s'est passé en suède que baisser
brutalement les impôts pour notamment la
position du capital ça va créer un choc
et donc une relance de l'investissement
bon donc on me disait tout à l'heure
c'est un pari mais c'est intéressant de
réagir à la polémique encore président
des riches puisqu'on voit bien quand
même
emmanuel macron est en train de
s'appuyer sur sa jambe gauche hier nous
a parlé de sécurité et vous avez suivi
également il lance un chantier sur
l'entreprise
mais dans l'entreprise s'est pas
seulement l'entreprise des actionnaires
et il ya une demande notamment de
certains syndicats de la cfdt pour qu'il
aille beaucoup plus loin
donc il sent bien il sait pas équilibré
pour l'instant effectivement il a
démarré par les mesures libérales et
nous rattraper et donc pas de se se
rattraper pour insister là dessus mais
il faut juste ne pas oublier quelque
chose c'était dans son projet il ya une
force quand même dans son interview de
rappeler je fais ce que je dis
il faut quand même c'est l'une des clés
mais oui mais sauf que c'est un peu la
réalité à 6016 souvenons nous qu'il fait
françois hollande qu'il n'avait pas
parlé de baisser les impôts et qui a
fait la peau et ça a été sa première
mesure quand elle est arrivée à l'elysée
alors un petit chantier un parce qu'ils
nous renvoient à l'intéressement la
participation qui est quand même une
mesure gaullienne on attend la modernité
non je voudrais juste réagir à cette la
chose sur laquelle vous nous fait réagir
on est resté dans la campagne un
président qui reste sur les thèmes dans
la lignée de son passage à bercy socio
économique
je trouve que c'est très en
contradiction avec l'interview fort
intéressante qu'il avait fait dans le
point et celle tout aussi intéressante
qu'il a fait dans le spiegel
où il nous parle d'héroïsme politique de
projeter les français vers autre chose
est ce autre chose hier on n'a pas
entendu on est resté est ce que c'est
bien est ce que c'est le sens des
institutions j'en sais rien mais je
trouve qu'il ya un décalage très
frappant entre la promesse de président
qui nous projette rennes ou français
vers un nouvel espoir et le discours qui
reste très terre à terre sur
l'ajustement de délivrer les premiers
minerais bercy je trouve et où je trouve
que là dessus
la promesse d'avoir un président qui
nous transforme n'est pas tenu et on va
s'arrêter là dessus merci à tous les
deux d'avoir participé à ce match
l'entretien du jour nous recevons axel
kahn grand généticien gars nous
présenter son livre jean un homme hors
du temps et puis nous dira lui aussi ce
qu'il a pensé des déclarations d'
emmanuel macron sur la gpa et la pma ce
sera juste après une courte pause à tout
de suite une fonction est en plein boum
c'est l'ex président après les cartes
postales nicolas sarkozy qui donnait de
ses nouvelles en sillonnant la france
celle de françois hollande qui gardent
les honneurs des moments officiels et
peut enfin goûter aux joies simples de
saïfi mais est il vraiment content de
cette nouvelle vie où ces images
qu'acheter ali stratégie
cette semaine des as billon en tout bien
tout honneur la vie d'un ex
déshabillons-les demain à 23 heures sur
public sénat l'info dans le rétro c'est
un regard sur l'actualité à travers
l'histoire
en pratique si on regarde l'histoire
longue un certain nombre de réformes ont
été mises en échec par la rue on peut
pas contester que la rue juin euros
chaque semaine
l'historien fabrice d'almeida décrypte
et analyse des faits d'actualité à
travers des images d'archivés de l'ina
un gouvernement ne peut que distribuer
les frais la 307 sur le problème qui se
pose encore aujourd'hui une autre façon
de comprendre l'actualité
l'info dans le rétro ce soir à 23h sur
public sénat
de retour dans vpl pour l'entretien avec
notre invité axel kahn bonsoir merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation médecin
généticien vous venez nous voir pour ce
livre jean un homme hors du temps et cet
homme gens c'est votre père il s'est
suicidé il ya 47 ans en vous laissant
une lettre à vous spécifiquement ce
livre c'est votre réponse à cette lettre
je n'ai pas ma réponse en réalité chez
[Musique]
on va dire la mise en oeuvre d'un projet
tout à fait singulier lorsque mon père
s'est suicidé il m'a manqué c'est une
lettre qui commence par cher axel je
m'adresse à toi comme sans doute le plus
capable de faire durement les choses
nécessaires et elle se termine par
l'injonction que vous avez rappelé
soient raisonnables et humain
et puis la première chose nécessaire que
j'ai fait qu'ils étaient très dures que
les gendarmes m'ont demandé de faire
c'est de reconnaître le corps qui était
en pièces vous imaginez le choc le train
lancé à grande vitesse de la csg sur le
rail voilà des dites vous avez
d'épouvantables et j'ai trouvé que
c'était pas possible d'en rester là
alors pendant très longtemps pendant des
décennies je me suis surtout focalisé
sur soient raisonnables humains en me
demandant qu'est ce qu'il a voulu me
dire par là qu'est ce que c'est qu'être
humain et est ce que à ses yeux
agissant comme j'agis il considérait que
je le suis et je ne pouvais pas revenir
plus avant à la première raison qu'il
donnait pour m'avoir écrit cette lettre
je m'adresse à toi comme étant le plus
capable de faire durement les choses
nécessaires parce que la première étape
interprétation de ces deux phrases
s'était un peu brutale mon fils ça vais
m'en servir
je vais te dire ce que tu dois faire tu
es capable de le faire parce que tu es
dur mais un scrupule avant de nourrir
tout de même il faut que je lui dise à
ce fils un peu dures soient raisonnables
et humain et ça vous voyez c'était pas
possible et de rester avec ce père en
pièces et de rester avec avec cette
image là et j'ai eu
un projet alors qui est fou totalement
fou qui est de redonner vie au père pas
lui répondre de lui redonner vie
je ne parle pas dans ce livre c'est lui
qui parle c'est à dire que j'ai pendant
et regarder oui je la kg pendant des
années des années
luçon avril à une oeuvre considérable de
très grande qualité considérable je les
lui gelé relu souvent année compliquée
je dois dire et puis un moment donné je
me suis totalement revêtu de sa
personnalité dans la peau dove savez il
ya un film célèbre dans la peau de
markovic moi c'est dans la peau de jean
kahn et lorsque j'ai écrit ce livre
l'idée était voilà j'ai 73 ans il
n'avait pas tout à fait 54 ans quand il
est mort
eh bien on va inverser les rôles là
c'est un fils qui va engendrer son père
et un fils qui va donner vie à son père
avec le recul vous diriez qu'il avait
raison vous étiez le plus capable de
faire durement les choses nécessaires
il a bien fait je veux dire c'était à
vous et pas le frère je pense qu'il ya
des raisons j'étais le benjamin donc
c'était paradoxal mais j'étais médecin
donc j'étais habitué effectivement à une
certaine dureté de la vie à la
souffrance et à la mort
pour cela oui c'est une fête c'est une
des raisons et c'est vrai qu'il y en a
au moins une violence quand j'étais
jeune c'était une violence physique je
me battais tout le temps je rentrais en
sang en loques
et puis ensuite cessé de me battre quand
même été j'anime exxon 26 ans c'étaient
des gens cela eût été dommage mais je
gardais une violence gta militant
communiste à l'époque comme un militant
commises de 26 ans avec le sectarisme
qui va avec et ça c'est l'épouvanté un
peu si vous voulez et par conséquent oui
pour les raisons professionnelles et du
fait de cet engagement et de cette
manifestation d'une certaine violence
intellectuelle je pense en effet qu'il
n'avait pas tort et vous lui en voulez
de
vous avoir laissé ce point immense sur
les épaules non c'est à moi que j'en
veux à mais mes deux frères en penser la
même chose parce que notre père était
aussi un pédagogue un philosophe et en
permanence il était le le papa oiseaux
la maman oiseaux qui donnait la becquée
au zoo aux oisillons grand loisir
j'étais le plus jeune est âgé de 26 ans
donc
jean-françois lui il en avait 32 et on
était tellement avides de prendre cette
pitance d'une incroyable richesse qu'on
n'a pas vu qu'il était malheureux et
chats c'est très difficile très
difficile de se pardonner vous savez
quand j'imagine je voudrais qu'on parle
aussi de l'actualité puisque d'ailleurs
vous vous tenez un blog sur différents
sujets notamment sur la pma notamment
sur la pierre macé pour que ça avance
très très bien que je voulais en venir
vous avez levé vu venir
vous savez qu emmanuel macron en a parlé
hier soir on va l'écouter je vais vous
demander comment vous le comprenez et si
vous êtes d'accord
quand il s'agit de la procréation de la
filiation etc je souhaite que nous ayons
un vrai débat moi ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que je suis pour reconnaître
des droits égaux à nos concitoyens
je suis très sensible au respect de la
filiation
c'est aussi pour ça que je suis contre
la gestation pour autrui parce que je
j'ai une conception de la dignité du
corps de la femme
je ne pense que cette conception
philosophique est la nôtre ne permet pas
qu'on puisse porter un enfant pendant
neuf mois pour le compte d'un autre et
je souhaite qu'on puisse pas passer de
la pma à la gpa subrepticement alors
évidemment ce n'est qu'un extrait juste
avant il dit qu'il est pour l'ouverture
de la pma toutes les femmes au nom de
l'égalité de tous les citoyens mais en
revanche contre la gpa est ce que vous
ne trouvez pas cela même paradoxal de
dire oui à la pma pour l'égalité de
toutes les femmes mais non à la gpa
alors que certains hommes voudraient
avoir des enfants
elle voulait guen non ce n'est pas
paradoxal et c'est logique il n'y a pas
de raison on n'a pas le temps si vous
voulez des détails et mais en termes de
d'avancées sociales de nouvelles lois
pour la procréation pour l'affiliation
chez le même raisonnement que pour la
volonté qu'avait les personnes de même
sexe de se marier
ce sont des citoyens le mariage est un
contrat civil
ces citoyens voulaient avoir le bénéfice
de ce contrat civil qu'on regardait de
près y avait vraiment aucune raison de
s'y opposer
maintenant les femmes elles vont temps
pas en suisse mais surtout en espagne ou
en belgique pour avoir une fécondation
avec sperme de donneur est presque
toutes n'ont aucun problème
la seule limite effectivement c'est
l'argent est ce que c'est normal non ce
n'est pas normal
d'autre part on pouvait avoir un doute
le président a parlé de la filiation est
ce que les enfants vont perdre une
chance de n'avoir pas de papa moi je
fais partie de ceux à ces
traditionalistes qui considère que quand
on peut avoir une maman et un papa et
que la maman le papa aime l'enfant et
que l'enfant m
maman et papa c'est mieux mais bon la
réalité c'est qu'il ya des centaines de
milliers de familles
qui sont monoparentales ou bien qu'ils
sont hétérosexuels mais il faudrait
mieux qu'elles fussent monoparentales
compte tenu du comportement du père la
réalité c'est cela et on commence
maintenant avoir une très importante
étude un recul considérable sur l'avenir
psychologique sous tous ses aspects des
enfants qui sont nés dans ces
conditions-là de couple homoparental ou
de femmes seules
il n'y a pas de différence qui peut être
perceptibles par rapport aux enfants qui
sont nés on va dire de couples
hétérosexuels habituel donc il n'y a pas
de raison de s'y opposer maintenant pour
la gpa me suis dit mais promise
je vais vous répondre immédiatement pour
la gpa il ya une tierce personne
c'est à dire que le désir des hommes
homosexuels d'avoir un enfant il est
légitime sur l'amour et légitimer leur
désir d'avoir un enfant est légitime
d'ailleurs l'adoption leur est ouverte
mais maintenant s'ils veulent qu un
enfant biologique
il faut effectivement qu'il fasse entrer
la fonction gestatrice d'un tiers d'une
femme dans le circuit marchand passe
assez simplement et des équipes total
mois ce contre quoi je suis ce n'est
évidemment pas la légitimité du désir
d'enfants d'hommes en tout cas ce contre
quoi je suis comme le président en
l'occurrence c'est effectivement que
l'on considère comme un progrès de faire
entrer la fonction gestatrice des femmes
dans les circuits marche bien ça n'est
pas avait encore un cap supplémentaire
qu'il ne faut pas franchir on dit cela
aujourd'hui mais ce qu'on dira cela dans
10 15 ans 20 ans je n'en sais rien vous
me demandez qui venaient pas en train
d'ouvrir à demander qu'il est mon je ne
crois pas profondément parce que dans la
sphère de la pma pour les femmes il n'y
a pas de pierre personnage bon vous me
direz le donneur de sperme et le don de
sperme
il est gratuit il est anonyme donc ça
n'a strictement rien à voir
en revanche payé une femme pour que
pendant neuf mois elle accepte d'être
considérés uniquement comme une matrice
vivante artificiel c'est tout à fait
différent et donc il y a une différence
un saut qualitatif entre les deux est
l'argument de la pente glissante d'apn à
conduire est à la gpa
je le récuse le refuse dans le cas de la
gpa il y à une tierce personne et
l'opposition vient de l'idée que l'on a
de l'intérêt réel de cette pièce
personne merci accepté d'avoir été notre
invité ce soir dans l'entretien douwe pl
je rappelle le titre de votre livre jean
un homme hors du temps merci infiniment
c'est la fin de cette émission trop
trouve demain à la même heure sur public
sénat ne manquaient pas l'invité de
territoire d'infos demain matin c'est
marlène schiappa la secrétaire d'état à
l'égalité homme femme je souhaite une
très belle soirée est restée au coeur du
débat
[Musique]
e